jean-luc mois de la prévention au frat
ce qu'il ne fallait pas louper avec
daphné bürki et fabrice et moi parce que
je sens que vous avez beaucoup de choses
à dire sur la télé sous les allez c'est
parti
olive aller tout de suite une question
pour vous allez on y va bonjour je
m'appelle joël comme les invités rendent
de plus en plus tard dans l'émission je
voulais savoir si on les voyait quand
même tous ou si certains arrivés après
le générique de fin d'activité
exceptionnellement on sent le privilège
on sent la privilège et c'est vrai que
les invités rendent de plus en plus tard
dans l'émission cher joël mais c'est
pour mieux les mettre en valeur
surtout que cyril nous gâte rabais mais
si vous regrettez
non non pas du tout l'émission atteint
des scores de plus en plus
impressionnant bas tout le monde veut
participer à notre programme
par exemple il ya quinze jours nous
avions eu en exclusivité mondiale nos
pieds hôtel novotel et aymeric bonnery
pris un gros coup et je vais pas vous
mentir on était tous comme des fous pour
laquelle notre invité éric beaudry
et
j'adore jouer or ces garçons je sais que
vous l'aimez aussi beaucoup et l'ol
les grecs story et les données du côté
éric mathieu
non mais regardez ce que j'espère que
les gens regardent passer casto ya pas
toujours dans les invités il ya deux
semaines nous recevions des candidats
qui vont faire plaisir à daphné puisque
c'étaient des candidats de adam
recherche et vous et c'est vrai qu'on
était tous fébriles
la première fois des gens nus allait
venir sur le plateau
j'étais content en présence de jean
michel maire normalement ces
fécondations direct mais non je suis
mauvaise langue
c'est une fécondation in plateau c'est
ça
ivan basso s'est bien comportée
jean-michel il est resté très
respectueux très classe regardez la
discrétion
oui
viendra alors c'est ce soir caroline
vous présenter cette émission créée à
tant de cherchell on a mis les regards
âme et son armée n'est pas observé
petite fille du lycée juste fan de
silence a poussé parce que vous aurez
remarqué au passage la gêne de valérie
bénaïm par contre ça contraste bien
c'est une femme pudique valérie ou
jusqu'où un soc parce que même à l'écho
regardez la nudité ça la dérange admirer
son malaise je m'appelle trois ans je
suis conseiller de vente pour un réglage
si je devais me décrire je dirais que je
suis une personne attentionné généreuse
sur radio
mais mon amour souvent je m'engage trop
vite et ça m'a sûrement porter des fois
je suis lancé dans cette aventure c'est
pour aller au delà des jugements sans
vie dans l'opérateur telenor et monde
comprend rapport à mai
alléluia
j'essaie de laisser s'occuper formation
qu'elle hésité à se taper ses sincères
excuses à l'armée valérie c'est la
pudeur les valeurs d'autrefois notre
maman à tous dès qu'on la voit on envie
de la tétée fakoly
j'ai essayé ça allait passer
on fait du vélo s'il faut ou non mais
c'est pour ça que dans l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste bas tout le monde
adore regarder
ces grands gagnants de cette première
édition gfr ces rives sont là 7 rentrer
la mariette on te dit alors tu habites
aurait dit au nom maintenant
je vais
bravo
allez vous êtes la série bah oui moi je
sais vous divertir avant vous
heureusement que vous êtes là il est
approuvé m sont là c'est dans
je sais pas pourquoi vous voulez mais
c'est la foir'fouille
de la santé toujours à la changer
quel est tombé dans le parc privé a pu
choquer c'est quand même ce qu'a dit
bertrand chamerois parce que bon on va
pas se mentir c'était prévisible parce
que bébert il a en pleine crise
d'adolescence il est incontrôlable
il vient même sur le plateau avec ses
rollers vous ne devez pas à verser
cela allait aller bonne cause d'une
chute a fait compter deux jours jeunes
il ya aussi julien courbet a alors lui
dans l'équipe c'est le plus connecté
il aime bien posté d'evine souffert des
photos ils adorent ça il adore ça et
enfin des photos tous les week-ends il
nous régale ses seins et ses photos que
c'est quand tu les propulse aspect
commander ses ficelles qui êtes sûr oui
j'y crois pas je crois pas et vous allez
voir marié l'orphelin non plus crois pas
que ça s'appelle comme ça et baisse ou
pas du tout la gueule de julien les
fiches le faire
si j'arrive à ce n'est pas gagné
génération et des garçons comme ça nous
paraissait vraiment à des productions
prenez tellal jouer c'est fantastique on
se pinçait via josé la caf est bon pour
en revenir à la question initiale à part
l'entrée tardive des invités une des
grandes nouveautés l'émission ce sont
les coming next
ah oui qui se résume à des séquences où
cyril parle à la caméra et nous on fait
des sourires derrière au début ça a duré
30 secondes mais maintenant ce sont des
émissions à part entière peut laisser
parler son génie le problème c'est que
c'est souvent hors antenne donc pour que
ça soit pas gâché mon nom alors si
navarro coûte moins belge peut douter
tant qu'une et je te jure si jetons
reprend je prends quelques coups ont
fédéré ça ils ont fait une bouteille de
vin sur la tête de ma mère
il ya des moments vous êtes crever vous
fatiguez pas parler comme ça mathis tard
et ça c'est parce que c'est pas moi
c'est la série pas moins été fait par
professionnel et l'autre qui dispose de
bien faire du raisin avec des coups il
fallait y penser
créativité quand tu nous tiens mais bon
les comic books sert aussi à d'autres
choses comme on le fait dans le hall 2d
vite on voit passer des gens notamment
les dirigeants de la chaîne car notre
grand patron ara aprikian c'est toujours
impressionnant croiser son boss avant la
prise d'antenne regardez-la plus
intimidés c'est normal à gré
on va se retrouver lausanne sport sur
des mythes et jallet tapis
et on a pas on l'a on n'a pas le
contrôle
non parce que pour voir la tête d'art à
caen mais non c'est pas ça passerait
dans thalassa
ah ouais mais c'est une entaille
précédent ça car à l'époque du pendant
trois jours les tronçons intensifs le
pays n'aura eu sur d'augmentation
alors seulement avant la prise d'antenne
permet aussi à cirer de nous faire
partager ça suffit ces secrets les plus
intimes est ce que voulais vraiment voir
ce à quoi wipo souvenirs les plus
intimes
quoi bonjour de la pieuvre
non non non la barbe j'étais pas bien
j'avais la quiche aux bords des simples
bref j'avais la quiche au bord du four
et j'avais le tartare au fonds us qui
bavent hischier [ __ ] relais volet web
a par contre la bouche aux chrétiens la
pierre regardez le top partie juin 10h
en plus
je vous avais prévenu va loin c'est pour
ça que le bonjour de la peur des fois il
sent pas bon
j'étais gp derrière quoi tout à l'heure
j'ai un autre secret de vous non si vous
réfléchissez on verra si j baptiste
dumas notre secret oui bah qui a dit
mathieu maquette baptiste j'ai beaucoup
fait pas ça chez vous c'est ça alors à
part ça en bref isabelle a essayé de
faire une micro sieste en se servant de
sa pancarte
jean-michel mais rossi dont les effets
rapides sur me chabert a eu un éclair de
lucidité on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
15e
cette fois il est réputé mais non mais
c'est bien qu'ils sont bien fausse
prépare à tout même au pire
ah oui vous saviez pas comment lui dire
maintenant non moi je sais qu'il est
préparé la tête de la plus étrange du
moins est attribué à julien courbet a
alors qu'ils se regardent et au ralenti
dans les questions en matière
alors vous allez voir c'est très bizarre
parce que quand il se regarde on
ralentit il réagit au ralenti
c
alors le secret le plus étonnant
maintenant ils considèrent maintenant on
va notamment n'ont pas de préliminaires
on y va elle et cyril hanouna syrie vous
savez sans doute pas mais cyril est très
superstitieux
donc comment fait-il pour être aussi au
top dès le début de l'émission et bien
avant de prendre l'antenne
il a des rituels
on
et oui on se porter chance ils pissent
dans sa poubelle
mais je vous rassure je vous rassure
qu'elle sait pas salle parce qu'après il
me la poubelle dans la loge des
chroniqueurs c
c'est vrai
on était haut on n'était qu'une petite
équipe et non mais c'est alors sachez
que quand il écrit la rubrique je ne
savais pas qu'ils auraient baptiste
voilà c'est tout
c'est un pipi dans une économie était à
cinq mètres de là binaire sanitaire
alors c'est complémentaire
allez merci les on enchaîne avec les
conversations la plus surréaliste de
blizzard cgg dix autres écoles à quoi
sont elles plus surréaliste de l'année
d'après vous on la doit qui abat mon
avis la belle morini bosc
non non non non non jean michel maire
est carrément ya valérie qui fait ça non
non c'est une triplette si on les doit à
ses trois génies regardez jamais moi
aujourd'hui
il fait des mamours avec le sais pas ce
que tu me connais au micro à quelques
semaines d'élections
ah les cons
je ne sais plus si on met un micro
casque on entendrait n'ont pas grand
chose un q5
mais parce que le core i try l'acide
travail pour certains que je devrais pas
longtemps à bout de cathédrale
tu vois pas ce que
il ya de la place et la page perdu pied
ça suit mes pensées abbasse sodi par
quoi gagner coûteux
c'est un jeune homme est là
mais ne permettrait pas que valérie
benaïm puisse rentrer dans ce genre de
bonnes réactions et puis finalement on
s'y rendre facilement à ossama allez
c'est bon elle est une question oui on
non question bonjour je m'appelle sylvia
on voit de moins en mois il a belle
morini-bosc danser dans votre émission
est ce que c'est parce qu'elle a des
soucis ou juste des problèmes d'arthrose
rejoint sur ce il ya tout va bien pour
isabelle qui a toujours autant le sens
du rythme comme elle aime à se vanter
regardez là juste un exemple vous
montrer que la science du rythme on va
lancer la musique de happy birthday de
stevie wonder
tout de suite elle va embrayer et
suivent le mouvement ça s'appelle avoir
l'oreille absolue
alain pluss
ça c'est mon idée vu son émission c'est
impressionnant quant à ses chorégraphies
ces belles ne pense pas moins elle
prépare et justes dans la plus grande
discrétion sa collection printemps été
bonne nouvelle elle est prête elle est
prête donc tout de suite un nouveau
numéro de danse avec
alors
la bataille
ap langue
ça
ah ah
je
ces choses là
il
je
ce sera mieux les rênes
gmail à québec
bravo